[Musik]
12 Uhr mittags herzlich willkommen zum
internationalen Frühschoppen live aus
Köln an diesem Sonntag ein Tag an dem
der Krieg in der Ukraine unvermindert
hat weitergeht aus der Nacht werden
russische Angriffe auf eine Militärbasis
in der Nähe der polnischen Grenze bei
leviv gemeldet die Menschen aus der
zerstörten Stadt mariopol können auch
weiterhin nicht evakuiert werden der
Krieg wird lange dauern diese
Befürchtung wächst und Gespräche in
dieser Woche zwischen beiden
Außenministern und auch ein langes
Telefonat von Frankreichs Präsident
macron und Bundeskanzler Scholz gestern
mit Putin auch diese Gespräche schaffen
nicht einmal eine Waffenruhe der Westen
unterstützt die Ukraine militärisch und
finanziell und setzt geschlossen auf
harte Sanktionen ein Eingreifen der
nahto soll unbedingt verhindert werden
aber wie lange lässt sich das
Durchhalten angesichts der humanitären
Katastrophe unser Thema im Frühschoppen
Krieg in der Ukraine reagiert der Westen
richtig herzlich willkommen noch einmal
ihnen und ihnen auch hier bei mir am
Tisch ich darf Ihnen meine Gäste
vorstellen aus Deutschland Georg Mascolo
Leiter des rechercheverbundes von NDR
und Süddeutscher Zeitung mit der
Perspektive aus den USA Casting
clüvereschbruck Politikwissenschaftlerin
beim global public policy-institut und
das Russland an der Rose sie ist
Deutschland Korrespondentin des
russischen Radiosenders Echo moski den
es auch nicht mehr gibt das war der
letzte freie Sender Russlands inzwischen
auch von den Aufsichtsbehörden
geschlossen und die Mitarbeiter können
Ihre Inhalte noch über Youtube und
soziale Medien verbreiten und für die
Ukraine Roman goncarenko von der
Deutschen Welle arbeitet für die
russische und die ukrainische Redaktion
herzlich willkommen und Sie liebe
Zuschauer können sich auch beteiligen
sie kennen ist beim Frühschoppen sie
können bei uns anrufen und können auch
vorher Ihre Fragen über Twitter und
Facebook stellen wir freuen uns auf Ihre
Fragen und Anmerkungen
aus der Ukraine hier nach Deutschland
holen können auch Familie ist noch in
der Ukraine wie erfahren Sie diesen
Krieg an diesem Sonntag
ich glaube für viele Ukraine ist das
Leben seit dem Sven 24 Februar nicht
mehr dasselbe auch in meinem Fall ich
schlafe kaum ich wache auf mit Gedanken
über die Menschen die dann noch sind
also es geht nicht nur um meine Familie
sondern um mehr als 40 Millionen
Menschen die da jetzt sind ich hatte
Glück und konnte Teil meine Familie nach
Deutschland begleiten vor allem Frauen
und Kinder und ich habe sie dann an der
rumänischen Grenze abgeholt sozusagen
und dann weiter begleitet und als ich da
war an dem Grenzübergang habe ich
mehrere Stunden in dieser Schlange
verbracht wo vor allem Frauen und Kinder
stehen bei Isis Kälte und das war schon
ein sehr starkes Gefühl von das darf
nicht sein wir haben alle glaube ich
mehrmals solche Bilder gesehen aus
anderen Ländern aus Syrien Irak wo
Flüchtlinge dann unter großem Leid ihr
Land verlassen müssen alles zurücklassen
müssen und das habe ich jetzt
unmittelbar erlebt das hat mich sehr
stark beeindruckt und was mich auch
beeindruckt hat war die Hilfe auf der
rumänischen Seite wo sofort praktisch
die Menschen in Empfang genommen wurden
wo erzählte aufgestellt wurden mit Essen
Trinken wo man sich ein bisschen
aufwärmen konnte was mir auch noch in
Erinnerung bleibt ist eine Fahrt nach
Bukarest im Zug und da saß eine Frau aus
der Ukraine aus der Stadt tschernowitz
neben mir eine ethnische Russen das
heißt sie ist ukrainische Staatsbürgerin
aber hat russische Eltern und sie hat
russisch gesprochen und hat gesagt wie
verwundert sie ist also sie lebt quasi
in der Mitte der westliche Ukraine die
laut russischer Propaganda oder laut
putin war lauter Nazis herumlaufen und
wo russische Sprache unterdrückt wird
und sie sagt ich habe nichts davon ich
lebe seit Jahrzehnten hier nichts davon
habe jemals gespürt niemand hat mich
hier bedroht oder irgendwie beleidigt
weil wir gehen russisch sein und sie hat
gesagt ich fahre jetzt nach Rumänien wo
meine Kinder sind aber dann kehre ich
zurück in meine Stadt das hat mich sehr
sehr beeindruckt Frau Rose wenn nichts
hören auch dann schließt sich ja direkt
die Frage an wie erfahren Menschen in
Russland von diesem Krieg es gibt ja
ganz strenge Zensur ihre Radiosender
wurde verboten was hören Sie noch wie
wird dieser Krieg wahrgenommen Russland
da die
oppositionellen Sender verboten sind
kann man die meisten Nachrichten nur aus
den Fernsehsendern vom ersten und
zweiten Fernsehsender bekommen und es
gibt da auch natürlich Radiosender wo
man dann diese Nachrichten verbreitet
und die Zeitung gibt es kaum welche
Internet nutzt man
zu nehmen nur zu privaten Zwecken ist es
nicht so dass die russische Bevölkerung
geübt ist im Internet nach Informationen
zu suchen sondern
sie schließen sich in Gruppen nach
Interessen und ich war erschrocken als
ich eine Befragung gestartet habe in
meinem Umfeld
die Leute gesagt haben dass sie bei tik
tok zum Beispiel eben sehen die
nazi-bilder und die Bilder von
Unterdrückung der russischen Bevölkerung
wo die Fahnen verbrannt werden oder
diese georgischen Bändchen verbrannt
werden und alle denken dass was eben der
Creme durch die Propaganda vermitteln
will dass wirkt nur die Nazis Leben
genau und diese Propaganda in diesen
Fernsehsendern die ist allmächtig die
hat eine sehr große Verbreitung und im
Internet
die Nachrichten die man da sieht können
quasi nicht dagegenhalten weil
tatsächlich 99 Prozent der Bevölkerung
und dadurch Bescheid werden das heißt
sie würden sagen die Bevölkerung der
Großteil der Bevölkerung steht hinter
diesem Krieg ich denke schon weil
tatsächlich die Propaganda und die
Ausschaltung der oppositionellen Sender
dazu geführt hat dass die Menschen keine
un Informationen mehr aus unabhängigen
Quellen schöpfen können
russische Dienst von BBC hat sie
zurückgezogen
dann bleibt nur eine Zeitung die
novalisierter mit ihrer Webseite aber
diese Zeitung die hat auch darauf
verzichtet über den Krieg zu schreiben
und deswegen ist es leider so dass
die Menschen dadurch auch dass sie mit
den falschen Informationen gefüttert
werden nicht mehr differenzieren kann
Rock lieber erstmal wie präsent ist der
Krieg in den USA der Westen ist sehr
geschlossen das merken wir ganz stark es
gibt große finanzielle Hilfe auch aus
den USA wie präsent ist dieser Krieg er
wird über präsenter denn der Präsident
hat gerade auch in der State of the
Union noch mal betont wie wichtig jetzt
oder wie dieses Sinnbild dessen was ich
in der Ukraine abspielt Putins Krieg wie
wichtig das noch mal für seine
Verquickung ist von dem Gegenspiel
Demokratien gegen Autokratien wir wissen
das ist ein Pfeiler der Philosophie
eines Joe bidens einer einer Grundidee
seiner Präsidentschaft aber dennoch wir
sehen auch da dass es sich unter den
partei-anhängern deutlich spaltet die
Demokraten meinen Herr beiden machen
einen sehr sehr guten Job indem er wie
er mit den verschiedenen Hilfen
militärisch wirtschaftlich sei auf der
cyberdimension mit diesen Aggressionen
des russischen Präsidenten umgeht aber
wir sehen auf der Seite der Republikaner
dass ich da ein ziemlicher lagerkampf
entwickelt hat denn bis zu im Vorlauf zu
dieser Aggression gab es gerade auch im
Haus und Hof Sender vieler Republikaner
Fox News einen sehr bekannten
Journalisten sag mir mal
Anführungszeichen Kommentator der sich
in die Reihe von Vladimir Putin gestellt
hat und wir wissen auch dass der
Ex-Präsident Donald Trump aus seinem
Exil wenn wir was so wollen in malago
weiterhin diesem Krieg eine eine
Rechtschaffenheit zuspricht also es gibt
Teile der republikanischen Partei die
wirklich auf eine andere Seite gestellt
haben und es ist eine Perversion der
Partei von Ronald Reagan der natürlich
quasi als der kalte Krieger galt also
wir sehen es sorgt ordentlich für
Diskussionsstoff innerhalb der US-Medien
aber eben auch in der US-Politik aber im
Moment gibt es eben eine starke
Unterstützung vom Besten der Maske wir
haben da wir merken dass ja der Europa
ist sehr geeint die Amerikaner stehen
fest an der Seite Europas ist ist das
eine Einigkeit die standhält denken Sie
also jedenfalls tut sie es im Moment und
ich würde jedenfalls zum Ergebnis kommen
wenn wahr ist und leider ist es wahr
dass weite Teile im Westen auch hier bei
uns im Land viel zu lange Wladimir Putin
unterschätzt haben dann hat er sich ja
auch an der Stelle die Entschlossenheit
und Geschlossenheit des Westens
unterschätzt man sieht das an den
geradezu beispiellosen
Wirtschaftssanktionen von denen ich
glaube dass sie Russland sehr viel
schneller und sehr viel härter treffen
als
diejenigen die diese Ideen zu Papier
gebracht haben sich am Anfang haben
vorstellen können und jetzt Ringen wir
und das erleben wir ja an jedem Tag wie
wir damit umgehen dass wir uns
entschieden haben einer solchen
militärischen Aggressionen in
allererster Linie mit wirtschaftlichen
Sanktionen entgegenzutreten und wir
hören die Forderungen aus der Ukraine es
muss zu es muss zu weiteren
Waffenlieferungen kommen zu anderen
Waffenlieferungen kommen es muss zu
einer Flugverbotszone kommen es muss zu
einem Stopp der energieexporte kommen
und wenn Sie mich fragen wie steht es um
die westliche Geschlossenheit und
Entschlossenheit dann wird das in den
nächsten Wochen schwierig zu beobachten
sein ich glaube dass die Linie steht in
praktisch allen Ländern in der NATO das
ist kein direktes Eingreifen in diesen
Krieg geben darf die Linie ist auch fest
wenn es darum geht eine Flugverbotszone
nicht durchzusetzen weil man in der
direkte Konfrontation mit der Russischen
Föderation eintreten würde in der Frage
welche Waffen sollen geliefert werden
gibt es schon Unterschiede und die
härteste Auseinandersetzung werden wir
sehr schnell erleben in der Frage ob es
zu einem vollständigen Importstopp für
russische Energie aber auch für
russische Rohstoffe kommen wird und wenn
die schrecklichen Bilder die wir aus der
Ukraine sehen diese Häuserkampf wenn der
sich fortsetzen wird dann bin ich davon
überzeugt dass auch die jetzige Linie
der Bundesregierung zum Beispiel zu
sagen wir wollen das nicht wir wollen
einen solchen Importstopp dass das auf
Sicht gar nicht auszuhalten sein wird
der Druck dann auch einfach wechselt
was erwartet die Ukraine wir hören das
immer die Flugverbotszone jetzt gibt die
ihr fragt jemand weil das hat natürlich
viele große Sorgen Andreas Mirbach fragt
führt ein Eingreifen der NATO zugunsten
der Ukraine zwangsläufig zu einem
Atomkrieg mit Russland das spiegelt ja
die Sorgen wieder also wie sehr kann die
Ukraine diese Forderung aufrecht
erhalten mit dem Gefühl dass es halt
eben wirklich dann zu einem ganz
schlimmen Krieg werden könnte es ist
schon schlimm genug und es kann leider
noch schlimmer werden ich befürchte das
also die ukrainische Forderung Nummer
eins die wir von dem Präsidenten
selensky hören und von also eigentlich
ist das eine Forderung die auch ganz
normale Bürger immer wieder stellen in
sozialen Netzwerken oder in privaten
Gesprächen das ist diese Forderung nach
der Flugverbotszone die Herr maskollo
angesprochen hat und die der Westen aus
verständlichen Gründen nicht durchsetzen
wird ich finde das ist eine richtige
Entscheidung so sehr ich mir das auch
gewünscht hätte ein denn eine
Beteiligung an der
Flugverbotszone würde bedeuten dass das
NATO Kampfflugzeuge oder
Flugabwehrsysteme russische Flugzeuge
abschießen müssen das wäre eine
Katastrophe die wir uns nicht vorstellen
können und wollen
ich glaube das ist möglich etwas
Vergleichbares zu tun an Hilfe
militärische Hilfe an die Ukraine und
zwar tut der Westen jetzt schon sehr
viel aus meiner Sicht die Lieferant von
panzerbrechenden Waffen das ist alles
wichtig und hilfreich nur ein Punkt an
dieser Stelle meine persönliche
Einschätzung ist dass diese Frage
gehören auch in Deutschland immer wieder
und auch in den USA grundsätzlich im
Westen liest man das in den Zeitungen
hört man das dass die Ukraine jetzt die
Drähte Woche durchhält das wirkt oder
wird vor wahrgenommen wie ein Wunder
also viele haben damit gerechnet und
gingen davon aus dass die Ukraine zwei
drei Tage durchhält und dann ist vorbei
dann ist das Land wahrscheinlich besetzt
die Regierung gestützt gestützt unser
und dann müssen wir schauen wie wir
weiterkommen es ist nicht passiert und
ich glaube das ist deshalb nicht
passiert aus zwei Gründen und eins
natürlich die ukrainische resistance
also Widerstand und der Wille zu kämpfen
und zu sterben
aber nicht so unterschätzen sind auch
die Waffenlieferung die Wochen vor dem
Angriff passiert sind vor allem die
amerikanischen und die britischen wenn
man sich dieser Statistiken anschaut wie
erfolgreich Joker eminische Armee bis
jetzt gewesen ist mit
Panzerfäusten aus amerikanischer
Produktion diese javalance oder die
britischen endlos oder stingerraketen
mit denen Flugzeuge und auch
Hubschrauber vom Himmel geheult werden
das ist alles das Ergebnis von dieser
Lieferungen in letzter Minute wirklich
was bringen mich zu dem Schluss hätten
wir diese Lieferungen vorher gehabt und
die Ukraine hat darum gebeten dann wäre
die Lage die militärische Lage auf dem
Schlachtfeld auch eine ganz andere es
blieb-training praktisch keine Zeit sich
auf diesen Krieg vorzubereiten
genau
muss der Westen weiter solche Waffen
liefern eventuell Kampfdrohnen liefern
oder sonstige Waffen die dann dafür
sorgen dass die den Himmel verteidigen
kann und die Ukraine muss verstehen ich
hoffe das passiert auch dass diese
Forderung nach der Flugverbotszone die
ist leider momentan nicht realistisch
was passierte wir haben jetzt gerade ja
gehört dass jetzt in der Nacht diese
Militärbasis in der Nähe der polnischen
begrenze beschossen worden ist ist das
zu befürchten Frau Klüver dass das dass
da genau die Waffen aus dem Westen eben
geliefert werden wir wissen dass das ein
Ansatzpunkt ist wo die Waffensysteme
ankommen und dann verteilt werden über
das Land das ist natürlich ein ganz
strategischer Schachzug der Russen wir
sind hier im Krieg im 21 Jahrhundert
also das heißt nicht nur sind die
militärischen Basen ganz klar auf der
Landkarte verzeichnet aber man kann sie
eben auch durch ganz unterschiedliche
Systeme angehen das war jetzt ein ganz
traditioneller Angriff können noch
andere Dinge in im cyberbereich dazu
kommen nach dem die Russen noch nicht
ihre gesamten Geschosse aufgefahren aber
ich glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig die
Amerikaner haben in der letzten Woche
noch mal auch in verschiedenen
Testimonials in den verschiedenen
Ausschüssen dem
[Musik]
auslandsausschuss des Senates Victoria
Nuland die die Top Karriere Diplomatin
hat dort ausgesagt aus dem
staty-partment und der Geheimdienst die
die Geheimdienstchefs der USA bilburns
und avril hands die gesagt haben wir
hören sehr wohl was die Ukraine von uns
braucht und möchte wir nehmen das quasi
auch als bestellungsliste auf wir haben
den kanadischen Premierminister in
Berlin gehört vor einigen Tagen mir auch
gesagt hat ganz spezielle
nachtsichtkameras werden wir liefern wir
werden all das Spezialgerät was wir
anliefern können liefern und die
Amerikaner überlegen jetzt auch am
Reisbrett Dinge die vielleicht vorher
nicht vorstellbar waren nämlich
unterschiedliche Truppenverlegung nach
Polen nach Rumänien festere
Truppenverbände als wir uns das
vielleicht vorher hätten vorstellen
können also es wird sehr sehr weit in
diesem Sinne auch nach vorne gedacht
quasi alles vor der Flugverbotszone was
man im Grunde aber was besser gewesen
wenn hätte das vorher gemacht aber gut
das weiß man jetzt immer Frau Rose
inwieweit
in Russland weil es sind junge Soldaten
die die russischen Truppen darstellen
was hört man davon also hört man von den
Verlusten gibt es irgendeinen Punkt wo
man mehr wo und denken Sie das Putin das
erreicht dass seine Truppen viel
langsamer vorkommen als ursprünglicher
gedacht es gibt keine Meldungen über die
Verluste keine objektiven Meldungen
natürlich es gab irgendeine kurze
Meldung über 100 Soldaten die gestorben
sind oder 150 so
Größenordnung und das ist natürlich
nicht wahrhaftig dass
erfährt das Volk ja und auch nicht weil
die Zahl deren die gestorben sind auch
im Militär verheimlicht werden also das
ist tatsächlich so dass überhaupt keine
Kanäle gibt wie diese Information
verbreitet werden ich denke dass die
ukrainische Seite versucht das schon
auf verschiedenen Kanälen mitzuteilen
dass dort auch Gefangene gibt dass dort
auch
Opfer gibt allerdings kommt es auch ans
Volk nicht und ich glaube nicht dass
Putin überhaupt weiß wie es um seine wie
er sagt spezialoperation steht ich denke
dass Putin alle Informationen von seinem
Umfeld schöpft und ich denke nicht dass
diejenigen die um ihn herum sind
gewillt sind im wahrhaftigen
Informationen zur Verfügung zu stellen
ehrlich gesagt bezweifle ich das dass
überhaupt die Lage selbst objektiv
einschätzen kann weil er in seine
parallelen Welt lebt wo er nur von
Informationen
weiß die im
auf den Präsentierteller gegeben werden
und er
versteht nicht tatsächlich wie die Lage
sich entwickelt und in welche Richtung
sie entwickelt das bezeugt dass er
generell entlassen hat weil er ein
Wutanfall gekriegt hat weil
ich verstanden hat dass der Krieg nicht
weitergeht er hat gehofft dass es auch
sehr schnell geht hat gehofft dass die
Stärke der russischen Armee
überwältigend ist und
das zeigt uns dass er tatsächlich selbst
nicht im Klaren ist was da läuft und das
ist natürlich auch dann gefährlich dazu
passende Frage von Alexandra Amber auf
Twitter befürchtet niemand das Putin
wenn er als erst mal wegen der
Sanktionen mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht
und das Gefühl hat nichts mehr verlieren
zu können erst recht eskalieren wird
Herr Maske wie schätzen Sie das einmal
das zum einen hören Wutanfall und dann
wenn die Sanktionen noch fortgehen also
ist das nicht die Gefahr wo man denkt
man muss doch noch also das ist richtig
dass man die Gesprächskanäle auf jeden
Fall mit dem auch aufrecht ich will nur
noch einen Satz sagen wir erleben ja dem
Propaganda und Unterdrückungsapparat in
Russland in einer Art und Weise wie er
selbst für russische Verhältnisse in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten undenkbar
gewesen ist und ich würde daraus
jedenfalls Einschluss ziehen wladimir
Putin hat jedenfalls vor einem Teil und
ich hoffe einem großen Teil seiner
eigenen Bevölkerung
Angst er muss diese Geschichte erzählen
von den ukrainischen Faschisten er muss
sagen es handle sich in Wahrheit um
Friedenstruppen nicht mal sein
Propagandaapparat kann jetzt Bilder
Produzieren von Ukrainern die auch
einmarschierende russische
truppenbegrüßen also es gibt ein einen
Versuch die Wahrheit auszusperren wie
ich glaube wie sie im 21 Jahrhundert
dauerhaft irgendwie nicht gelingen wird
wir erleben jetzt dass die großen
tech-konzerne sich praktisch alle
zurückgezogen haben aus Russlands auf
der einen Seite verständlich auf der
anderen Seite verlieren damit übrigens
auch Medien auch Oppositionelle Wiener
Wahl nie ein Stück eine Plattform aber
auf Dauer wird er die Wahrheit aus
seinem Land nicht völlig aussperren
können so und jetzt zur Frage der
Eskalation ja das ist was uns alle hier
am Tisch und alle ja seit Wochen
begleitet wir haben jetzt heute morgen
erlebt diesen Luftschlag auf den Westen
der Ukraine ich würde sagen russland hat
das angekündigt russland hat gesagt die
wenn Waffen geliefert werden dann sind
diese Nachschublinien legitime Ziele
diese Waffen werden aus NATO-Staaten
sind nato-waffen die werden aus
NATO-Staaten in die Ukraine gebracht es
hat ähnliche Drogen schon gegeben er
benutzt auch im Bezug auf ökonomische
Sanktionen das Wort Krieg Herr Dr
Rumänien bereits gedrohte hat gesagt
wenn es dazu kommen würde das Reste der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe dort stationiert
würden das heißt er zieht immer wieder
rote Linien die er verändert von denen
wir letztlich nicht wissen welche davon
wird er tatsächlich als Kasus belly als
den möglichen Kriegsgrund begreifen und
damit versucht der Westen umzugehen in
dieser Situation
Wladimir Putin um jeden Preis einen Sieg
nicht zu gestatten aus Sorge was dieser
Mann noch tun würde wenn er in der
Ukraine gewinnen würde und auf der
anderen Seite keinen solchen Konflikt
herauf zu beschwören indem in den USA
wird es der in die der Korn hat Putin
der in die Ecke getriebene ziehen
genannt der wenn er denn tatsächlich
alles verliert man die möglicherweise
zuzutrauen ist einen Krieg vom Zaun zu
brechen der noch ganz andere Dimensionen
hat vor dieser schwierigen Aufgabe steht
der Westen im Umgang mit diesen Konflikt
und müssen
dann wenn man wenn man sagt das
wichtigste ist diesen Krieg zu stoppen
und einen weiteren schlimmen Krieg zu
verhindern muss man da nicht sagen dann
ist es müssen wir irgendwie Putin etwas
anbieten es gab ja die jetzt in dieser
Woche von Präsident selenski diesen
Vorschlag der Neutralität also sagen wir
können auch mal wir müssen nicht
Mitglied der NATO werden also diesen
Schritt dazu wie wir wir werden sie das
ja es gibt diese Frage immer wieder
sollen wir Putin irgendwas anbieten was
sein Gesicht wahren kann eine goldene
Brücke bauen heißt das und soweit ich
bin das ja skeptisch ehrlich gesagt denn
ich beobachte Russland schon seit vielen
Jahren und besonders in den letzten
Tagen und Wochen sehe ich überhaupt
keine Kompromissbereitschaft ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen das Putin sagt okay
die Ukraine wird nicht NATO beitreten
die Hälfte der Ukraine bleibt russisch
besetzt die andere Hälfte dort darf
existieren wir stellen Kampfhandlungen
ein das glaube ich nicht und ich kann
mir auch nichts vorstellen was die
Ukraine jetzt als Kompromiss sozusagen
annehmen könnten nachdem so viele
Menschen gestorben sind und viele
weiteren werden sterben
insofern denke ich
wir sollten auf jeden Fall die
diplomatischen Bemühungen fortsetzen das
ist sehr wichtig vor allem um die
Menschen die jetzt in diesen Städten
eingeschlossen sind in hartif in Kiew in
mariopole im Süden der Ukraine und auch
in anderen Städten dass diese Menschen
da rausgeholt werden und entweder in die
Westukraine oder nach Westen fliehen
können das ist das worüber wir
verhandeln sollen mit Wladimir Putin und
diese Woche des Gespräches mit den
beiden Außenministern wenn man danach
die Pressekonferenz vom russischen
Außenminister lavrov gehört hat dann das
war so das war eine Absage an
Friedensverhandlungen das war ganz klar
wir machen keine Kompromisse darauf
sagte wörtlich es geht um Leben und Tod
und das sollte man sich auch klar machen
für Russland Russlands Führung
geht es tatsächlich um Leben und Tod sie
dürfen es sich nicht erlauben diesen
Krieg auch irgendwie nur ein bisschen zu
verlieren und sie werden deshalb bis zum
Äußersten gehen
Demütigungen und stolz das sind die das
sind glaube ich die die zwei Punkte mit
denen sich der Westen jetzt wirklich
beschäftigen muss wir sehen einen
Präsidenten der gedemütigt worden ist
also der mit einer Hybris in diesen
Konflikt reinkam der sich genau das
vorgestellt hat jetzt wissen wir auch
langsam natürlich wie die Pläne
ausgesehen haben eines Vladimir Putin
und der ist ganz kurz zwischen er fühlte
er sich dann auch vorher gedemütte wenn
man immer sagte der Westen hat den
Kalten Krieg gewonnen zum Beispiel war
das ist der Demütigung das ist das was
aus der Sichtweise dass das lesen wir in
der können wir uns mal anschauen in der
Rede an der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz 2007 also die tats
immer das das Ende des Kalten Krieges
die die große Schmach war dass das 21
jahrhunderts das ist das das empfindet
er als als als völkische Demütigung also
für sich sein Volk und er hat es ja
gedreht indem er sich also diese diese
diese
Opposition zum Westen durch das tief
religiöse durch die dieser
entgegenstellung gegen westliche Werte
das fließt da ja alles ein und jetzt
aber diese zusätzliche Demütigung dass
das was er sich vorgestellt hat in der
Ukraine was ähnlicher hätte laufen
sollen wie Georgien oder Tschechien die
Themen vorher dass das nicht
funktioniert hat das macht diese
Situation da bin ich ganz bei Ihnen so
brandgefährlich natürlich muss die
Diplomatie weiter laufen aber wir müssen
eine Sequenzierung haben vom Westen wie
wir uns jetzt bestimmte Prozesse
vorstellen und da muss zur in im ersten
Moment muss glaube ich die ökonomische
Schlinge noch noch viel enger ziehen
denn dann wird es auch für diesen
Präsidenten mitunter noch etwas enger
etwas unbe
Rationalität müssen wir Rationalität in
den Fragen stellen Frau Rose wie stark
merkt man die Sanktionen in Russland
also die wirken auf welcher Art wirken
die sie wirken sehr stark und zwar
unerwartet schnell
vor zwei Wochen haben die Menschen mir
auch noch gesagt es gibt alles in
Geschäften wir haben keine Angst in
Banken gibt es Geld haben die Leute eine
Provinz mehr auf meine Interviewanfragen
gesagt und jetzt erzählen die selben
Leute dass das ja kein Salz oder kein
Zucker in Geschäften mehr gibt dass kein
Buchweizen vorhanden ist dass die Regale
sich zunehmend lernen und man steht
Schlangen von westlichen Geschäften wo
man eigentlich hofft noch irgendwelche
Kleidung zu ergattern von westlichen
Marken man steht sogar um die Kaffeepads
zu kaufen große Schlangen es ist
tatsächlich
war ein sehr große Welle von
Rückschlägen von westlichen Konzernen
der zurück sich zurückgezogen haben aus
Russland und man hat Angst dass man
wirklich keine Technologien mehr bekommt
dass man die Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
des Landes gekappt hat und
man will fliehen sind ja auch sehr viele
Menschen 300.000 glaube ich auch schon
aus Russland geflohen jeder der ein
Visum hat oder Geld zurückgelegt hat
will aus Russland weg wenn er nicht das
Regime unterstützt weil man weiß dass
man auch das wichtigste verliert und
zwar die Freiheit die Frage ist wie man
das unterstützen kann weil wenn die
Sanktion hat wirken wenn die Bevölkerung
merkt dass das schwierig ist um den
Druck auf Putin auszuüben wie kann der
Westen sehen sie deine Möglichkeit der
Maske dass man sagt man man versucht die
diese Bevölkerung zu stützen damit auf
diese Weise letztendlich vielleicht
Putin gestürzt wurde oder ist es völlig
naiv also das ist jedenfalls ein
ziemlich riskantes Spiel wenn wir uns
anschauen was Sanktionen am Ende sind
dann sind Sanktionen dafür vorgesehen
dass eine herrschende Elite diejenigen
die das Sagen in einem Land haben ein
bestimmtes politisches Verhalten
verändern abstellen und das eine
gewünschte Reaktion erfolgt bei den
Sanktionen die ich jetzt gegenüber
Russland sehe sind sie so breit dass
sich fürchte dass sie auch in einem
großen Umfang Menschen treffen die
überhaupt nicht auf Putins Seite sind
die nie oder die
größte Zweifel an seiner Politik haben
das heißt die Breite der Sanktionen die
wir jetzt verhängt haben Netflix Ikea
sie haben es gesagt lehrere Regale da
wird man sehr vorsichtig sein müssen
dass diese Sanktionen tatsächlich
diejenigen treffen die sie unbedingt
treffen müssen ich finde ehrlich gesagt
die am schwersten erträgliche
Vorstellung
das im Ernst Herr osmanov seine Yacht
von der sagt das ist nicht seine sei im
Hamburger Hafen doch noch abholen kann
aber das ist sehr schwierig wird es
Methana in russischen Supermärkten zu
kaufen das sollte jedenfalls nicht das
Ergebnis der Sanktionen sein so dass ich
hoffe dass diejenigen die sie verhängt
haben sie sehr regelmäßig anschauen und
Sagen sind dieses genau die Sanktionen
die wir unbedingt verhängen wollen und
um dann nicht missverstanden zu werden
ich halte das für absolut richtig dass
wir das tun aber wir müssen darauf
achten dass Sie das System treffen Sie
müssen das System Putin treffen wir
haben keine Auseinandersetzung mit allen
Menschen in Russland und wir sollten Sie
auch nicht suchen aber das dauert
natürlich bis das die fragt ihr ja und
wir wissen anders als wie als wir das in
den 90er Jahren wussten da kannten wir
das Politbüro wir mussten gern wir
wussten ganz genau was wir in
Gorbatschow an die Hand geben müssen
damit dem Politbüro das sagen kann was
das Politbüro dazu allen beeinflussen
konnte wiederum Herrn Gorbatschow zu
halten denn das war wichtig was wir
wenig haben und ich glaube da weiß der
Mascolo ganz richtigerweise darauf hin
ist ein ganz tiefes Verständnis für
diese verschiedenen also welche
Oligarchen haben den wirtschaftlichen
Einfluss auf diesen Staatspräsidenten
und welche haben wirklich auch noch
politischen und das liegt daran dass wir
eben in diesen wir haben so viel Zeit
verloren als Westen und so viel
Verständnis verloren weil wir immer
gedacht haben da die Russen die müssen
doch nach dem gleichen Rushmore actor
Model handeln wie wir das im Westen tun
die müssen doch daran den muss es doch
daran gelegen sein Russland tief zu
verankern im westlichen
Wirtschaftssystem etc und wir haben
gesehen wie dieser Staatspräsident die
Reserven aufgebaut hat durch die
Zentralbank wie er ganz anders gehandelt
hat wie über Jahre im Grunde genommen
das vorbereitet hat was wir jetzt in der
Sequenzierung gesehen haben in
Tschechien Georgien und jetzt in der
Ukraine und wie wir das nicht vorher
zusammengefügt haben das ist doch die
eigentlich wirkliche Tragik das ist
tragisch und hilft uns aber jetzt ja
nicht weiter deshalb noch mal die Frage
was können was sollte jetzt getan werden
muss man auch einfach ergonsteiner
darüber nachdenken wie könnte denn ein
ein Ende des Krieges aussehen also muss
man diese Perspektive mal einnehmen wie
könnte es denn wie könnte ein Frieden
aussehen
das ist eine schwierige Frage und ich
glaube wir sind noch nicht da wo wir
diese Frage beantworten können wichtig
ist aus meiner Sicht dass die Antwort
auf die Frage wer kann Putin stoppen wer
kann diesen Krieg stoppen aus meiner
Sicht ist die einzige Antwort ist nur
die Ukraine das Volk der Ukraine können
diesen Krieg stoppen aber nicht allein
mit westlichen Waffen und mit westlichen
Sanktionen wir haben gerade über
Sanktionen gesprochen alles richtig bin
voll dabei aber ich glaube wir müssen
einen Schritt weiter denken und sie
haben auch das Öl und gasthema
angesprochen Herr Mascolo ich glaube
diese Debatte die in Deutschland jetzt
geführt wird wir sind noch nie bereit
dieses Embargo einzuführen ich glaube
das wird in den kommenden Tagen
spätestens Wochen kommen müssen sonst
wird das solche Verluste in der Ukraine
geben mit denen die Deutschen die
Europäer aber der Westen insgesamt nicht
mehr normal schlafen wird also dieser
Krieg ist so monströs dass wir uns nicht
aussuchen können welchen Sanktionen wir
jetzt
ob wir vielleicht heute die eine oder
die andere Sanktion jetzt einführen
gegen Russland der Westen muss sofort
alle Kanonen rausholen ich meine jetzt
wirtschaftlich kann und die es gibt und
nur so kann dieser Krieg vielleicht
gestoppt und eingefroren werden und dann
weiter auf diplomatischen Wege
vielleicht gelöst werden noch ganz kurz
zu Sanktionen vielleicht zwei Sätze nur
russland hatte viele Jahre Zeit sich auf
diesen Krieg vorzubereiten spätestens
seit 2014 seit der kremerktion aber auch
später als wir sie mehr Putin 2017 zum
ersten mal offen darüber gesprochen hat
wir müssen uns unsere Wirtschaft auf
einen Krieg vorbereiten und viele
russischen Zeitungen hatten dann die
Schlagzeilen viel Puschen etwa einen
großen Krieg gegen wen denn doch nicht
gegen die Ukraine aber genauso ist es
gekommen wir alle haben das verschlafen
oder nicht ernst genommen
was würde das bedeuten wenn wir jetzt
wirklich auch von deutsche Sicht in
sagen wir machen diesen Importstopp von
Muskel und Kohle was wurde das bedeutet
das würde wahrscheinlich ja weiteres
Absinken wenn die Arme und bedeuten
denke ich aber die Sanktionen die schon
jetzt
beschlossen worden sind ich glaube die
greifen auch ich denke dass es ja sehr
wichtig ist auf diese Ebene der
physischen Qualität des Lebens
zu vermitteln dass
man dieses Regime nicht unterstützen
darf
ich habe sehr lange probiert mit Worten
Diskussionen dagegen zu kämpfen ich habe
probiert auch die Leute zu animieren zu
diskutieren ich habe die Frage gestellt
niemand wollte mich hören niemand wollte
hören Wissen Deutschland zugeht was man
in Deutschland dazu meint das heißt
diese Apathie diese lethargische
Einstellung diese Gleichgültigkeit des
Volkes ich bin froh dass die vielleicht
dadurch gebrochen werden kann erstmal
durch eine abne in den Westen und dann
vielleicht gibt es ja eine Ressort die
dazu führt dass die Leute verstehen dass
tatsächlich nicht der Westen schuld ist
das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal
passieren aber es wird nicht jetzt nicht
nächsten Wochen nicht in den nächsten
Monaten sondern irgendwann und für
diesen Krieg ist es eigentlich auch
irrelevant
die Einstellung des russischen Volkes
weil die Veränderung sehr sehr spät sein
werden und ich denke dass wenn man den
Krieg stoppen will dann wird man
wahrscheinlich auf die Flucht der
russischen Soldaten vom Feld hoffen oder
auf in vielen Putsch innerhalb des
Militärs das ist meine Einschätzung
beziehungsweise jemand wird etwas Putin
antun auch in seinem engsten Umfeld da
sind wahrscheinlich diese drei
Varianten Variablen die dazu führen
können dass der Kriege gestoppt wird
Deutschland hat ja bisher das nicht so
unterschrieben hat gesagt dass sie das
dass wir es eigentlich uns nicht leisten
können und das Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck sagt das hat eben extrem
Auswirkungen auf die Industrie hat
könnte eine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit nach
sich ziehen all das glauben Sie dass man
das durchhalten kann
also das sagt ja übrigens nicht nur
Deutschland sondern es ist die Mehrheit
der europäischen Länder die sagen dass
eine solche schnelle Entkoppelung von
russischen Energielieferungen nicht
möglich Sichtweise noch einmal darauf
hin damit man wir werden automatisch
sofort die Diskussion bekommen nach
Energie über russische Rohstoff
Rohstoffe zu reden in dem Bereich ist
Deutschland sind Teil Europas noch sehr
viel abhängiger das heißt ich habe ein
Verständnis dafür warum die
Bundesregierung und weite Teile Europas
sagen wir haben viel zu spät verstanden
ich meine wir haben die Annexion der
Krim erlebt und haben trotzdem Nord
Stream zwei weiter gebaut und so ich
glaube eine ganze Generation von uns
wird zurückschauen und sagen wie wir
bestimmte Dinge nicht haben sehen können
und wie wir so sehr in einen solchen
Konflikt so unvorbereitet rein
Schlafwandeln können das Russland ein
Partner ist und kein Feind des Russland
ein Feind wird das haben wir ja nicht
gedacht na gut ich würde zumindest mal
sagen das was wir im Moment erleben ist
der dritte militärische Überfall auf die
Ukraine und nicht der erste es ist ohne
Frage ist ist jetzt der größte uns einer
den wir auf eine ganz andere Art und
Weise wahrnehmen aber in meiner Zählung
handelt es sich hier um den dritten
kriegerischen Akt den Russland gegenüber
der der Ukraine begangen hat so bei den
Rohstoffen haben wir glaube ich zwingend
die Entscheidung getroffen dass wir raus
wollen und es geht um die Frage welcher
Zeitraum wird dafür zur Verfügung
stellen ich kann nur meine Position
wiederholen ich glaube wenn wir weiter
diese Bilder aus der Ukraine sehen und
möglicherweise noch schlimmere dann wird
es gar keine Alternative dazu geben dann
werden diese energieexporte enden weil
wir das als Gesellschaft anders gar
nicht aushalten werden weil wir es
politisch und gesellschaftlich nicht
aushalten werden selbst wenn es nicht
wollen wenn Sie mir eine Sekunde noch
gestatten weil sie gerade gesagt gefragt
haben wie kann eigentlich dieser
Konflikt enden
aus meiner Sicht ist in jedem Krieg die
erste und vordringlichste Aufgabe das
zunächst die Waffen schweigen das heißt
jede Anstrengung die im Moment
unternommen werden kann damit es
humanitäre korridorität gibt damit das
Töten endet das Morden an unschuldigen
Zivilisten muss selbst mit jemanden wie
Vladimir Putin der erste Versuch sein
und deswegen finde ich jeden Versuch mit
ihm zu sprechen jeden Anruf zu sagen
zumindestens eine Feuerpause zu
erreichen völlig richtig danach wird es
noch viel schwieriger werden wie kann
Lösung aussehen wie finden wir übrigens
auch eine Lösung wenn Vladimir Putin
diesen Krieg verliert und ich hoffe so
sehr dass er ihn verliert dass wir es
nicht auf eine lange Zeit mit einem
gedemütigten und dann möglicherweise
noch gefährlicheren Russland zu tun
haben sie sagen möglicherweise wird es
zu einem Putsch kommen aber wissen wir
denn überhaupt wenn es zu einem Putsch
käme ob wir hinterher eine Fraktion in
Russland erleben würden die
möglicherweise noch radikaler wäre als
wir stehen vor so vielen Ungewissenheit
dazu passen zwei Fragen vielleicht am
Christrose fragt auf Twitter gesetz den
Fall man würde Putin los wer oder was
kommt danach Ivan der schreckliche und
Walter sein Neumann fragt auf Twitter
wie sollte die EU nicht alle Hebel in
Bewegung setzen und Putin jetzt
abzusägen ich befürchte das ab 2024 ein
US-Präsident regiert der vielleicht sich
wieder weniger für EU Belange
interessiert also dieser diese Frage
nach dem ja nach der Perspektive also
wie soll man damit umgehen also noch ein
Zusatz dazu wir haben jetzt über den den
Druck nach innen gesprochen und die
Möglichkeit vorauszusehen was innen
möglich ist es gibt noch ein paar Hebel
die nach außen auch wirken können und
die USA hat sich in den letzten Wochen
da sehr reingehängt und zwar ist das zum
Beispiel Diplomatie mit China oder
Diplomatie mit Indien oder den Ländern
die sich enthalten haben der Stimme in
der unvollversammlung wir sehen
natürlich auch dass die Gespräche mit
wenn es so Ela aufgenommen worden ganz
interessanter diplomatischer Schachzug
gleichzeitig natürlich mit Saudi
abonnieren den Vereinten Arabischen
Emiraten da geht es natürlich vielleicht
in erster Linie wirklich um das ganze
Thema
Ölreserven erstmal und was man da machen
kann aber umgekehrt geht es auch darum
putinen da wo er vielleicht alliierte
sieht oder zumindest Partner sieht und
wir erinnern uns an die Sprache dieses
freundschaftsabkommens zwischen den
Chinesen und den Russen kurz vor den
Olympischen Spielen dass man ihnen da
versucht auch den die Luft zum Atmen
abzudrehen die Chinesen haben schon
gesagt was die Technologie angeht würden
sie gerade Halbleiter den Russen zur
Verfügung stellen bei umgekehrt haben
sie sie auch rausgeworfen aus der
asiatischen Investment und
infrastrukturbank das heißt die
Amerikaner und der erweiterte Westen
sollten sich fragen was kann man noch
tun von außen um den Druck zu erhöhen
auf Wladimir Putin dass er auch andere
Möglichkeiten nicht mehr sieht wir sehen
auch das Iran ihr die Iran Gespräche
natürlich jetzt stocken weil da auch
Russland Druck gemacht hat die
Sanktionen für sich so auszulegen oder
den sanktionserlass so auszulegen dass
sie vom Iran Dinge beziehen könnten die
Sie jetzt vielleicht bräuchten das macht
der Westen nicht mit auch da muss der
Westen dicht halten ich glaube das ist
Putin eigentlich ganz egal ist die
Außenwirkung ist im freien Flug der
läuft Amok jetzt und er wird dadurch
nicht gestoppt aber sie Leute die in
seinem Umfeld sind der Oligarchen
vielleicht die etwas zu verlieren haben
und wiederum auch seine nächste Umgebung
die wird davon betroffen sein eher nicht
Druck ich glaube Druck muss überall hoch
sein von ihnen eine besten Fall aus
diesen die sich was ich aus den
Sanktionen erschließt aber eben auch von
außen ich glaube Shisha in pink könnte
mitunter das Leben führen gleich mehr
Putin unangenehm machen aber da muss
eben der Westen umgekehrt schließen auch
Dinge anbieten also die diplomatischen
Verflechtungen die werden jetzt noch
durchaus interessante nehmen israel hat
auch eine Rolle gespielt ist auch nach
Moskau gereist Herr goracenko auf wen
setzen Sie
die Ukraine versucht ja also Präsident
Selens geredet vor dem britischen
Unterhaus er wird auch im Bundestag eine
Rede halten also wird zugesch werden all
das also auf wen hoffen sie da am
meisten sie meinen jetzt westliche
Politiker die ich weiß nicht am meisten
hoffen dir keine wahrscheinlich auf die
Amerikaner die bis jetzt am meisten auch
getan haben um diesen Krieg zu
verhindern indem sie ihre
Geheimdienstinformationen publik gemacht
haben indem sie Waffen geliefen haben
ich glaube das bleibt so aber natürlich
auch die Länder wie Großbritannien und
auch einige Länder noch in der
europäischen und die Waffen geliefert
haben Deutschland leider zu spät aber
immerhin ist es auch passiert darauf
hoffen die Ukrainer selbstverständlich
zwei kurze Bemerkungen Bemerkungen zu
dem was wir gerade besprochen haben ich
bin nicht überzeugt von dem Argument es
könnte ein schlimmerer
Präsident Diktator
autoritärer Herrscher wer auch immer in
Russland an die Macht kommen denn was
wer wäre noch schlimmer als Putin jemand
der sofort die Atomraketen losschickt
vielleicht passiert das auch unter Putin
in den kommenden Tagen in darf sich ich
dachte erinnern das was wir jetzt in
Ukraine erleben dieser dieser
furchtbarer Krieg der wurde in
russischen Medien seit Jahren seit
Jahren in politischen Talkshows sehr
detailliert aus diskutiert und sowohl
die Ukraine als auch hier im Westen
Leute die das gesehen haben die haben
das für Spinnerei gehalten und genau so
wird es jetzt umgesetzt eins zu eins und
in diesem Talkshows wurde auch über
Atomschläge gegen den Westen diskutiert
gegen Warschau zum Beispiel russisches
Militär hat das durchgespielt und sie
haben darüber gesprochen und darüber
gelacht in Talkshows und das sollten wir
tatsächlich ernst nehmen und vielleicht
eine ganz kurze Bemerkung zum Thema Öl
und Gas im Bagger
was jetzt noch zu selten in in deutschen
Medien diskutiert wird warum machen wir
nicht eine temporärer Maßnahme und sagen
wir stoppen jetzt
Gaslieferungen und earliferen aus
Russland für zwei drei Monate sagen wir
mal bis Juni und weil die mir Putin hat
jetzt Zeit nachzudenken wir weiter
vorgeht in der Ukraine warum soll nicht
wenn das so ist wie sie sagen dass wir
das alles nicht ernst genommen haben und
dass wir das jetzt ernster nehmen
müssten Herr maskuller muss darauf nicht
folgen dass wir uns auf einen Atomschlag
dann einstellen und entsprechend dann
härter noch reagieren
also wenn ich der Logik Folge der
Argumente
ich muss Ihnen sagen dass ich leider
überhaupt nicht wüsste wie man sich auf
einen Atomschlag vorbereiten könnte ist
ehrlich gesagt schlimm genug dass wir
heute an einem Sonntagmorgen an dem
Tisch hier über die Möglichkeit sprechen
müssten
ehrlich gesagt direkt nach dem Einsatz
der Atombombe haben diejenigen die was
davon verstanden haben nämlich die
Militärs den klugensatz zu Papier
gebracht das ist im nächsten Krieg
irgendwie nur Verlierer geben wird und
keine Gewinne mehr daran hat sich
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nichts geändert
und jetzt erleben wir alles was sie
sagen ist ja völlig richtig dass wir es
mit einem russischen Präsidenten zu tun
haben der übrigens nicht erst seit
gestern so eine besondere Affinität dazu
entwickelt hat mit Atomwaffen zu drohen
ich möchte übrigens erinnern dass er das
praktisch unmittelbar bevor der
Einmarsch in die Ukraine begonnen hat
getan hat indem er dieses nukleare
Manöver abgehalten hat
seitdem steigt die Rhetorik in diesem
Bereich
ich bin ehrlich gesagt froh dass die USA
und die NATO sehr vorsichtig und sehr
besonnen darauf reagieren
aber das ist letztlich genau die
Herausforderung wir haben es heute
morgen besprochen vor der man jetzt in
diesem Konflikt steht er darf ihnen
nicht gewinnen man darf ihn nicht davon
kommen lassen und gleichzeitig muss eine
wirklich große militärische
Auseinandersetzung zwischen der Nato und
Russland aus meiner Sicht unbedingt
vermieden werden und diese Balance zu
finden in den kommenden Wochen und
Monaten wird ungeheuer schwer werden
aber ist aus meiner Sicht die größte und
wichtigste Aufgabe in dieser Situation
Amerikaner haben es auch schon geübt sie
haben in der Obama administration einen
großen sogenannten Tabletop exercise
gemacht erst mit den deputes
durchgespielt wo aval hands die jetzt
quasi den innengeheimdienst anführt noch
ein deputer und dann mit den oberen also
mit dem Pentagon und die die Runde der
Depp beuties ist dazu gekommen dass nach
einem Nuklearschlag der Russen auch mit
kleineren Nuklearwaffen das Land so
isoliert wird und so einem
wirtschaftlichen Nordkorea gemacht wird
und die oberen dazu gehört auch der
damalige Pentagon Chef mein ehemaliger
Chef der die wiederum waren wieder
gleich beim Youtube destruction also
Atomwaffe gegen Atomwaffe das sogenannte
madprinzip-prinzip und was das aber
unterstreicht ist dass wir jetzt wenn
die Überlegungen am Reißbrett gemacht
werden und sie werden am Reisbrett
gemacht ich glaube das sollten wir uns
noch mal vor Augen führen das ist da
jetzt andere Möglichkeiten geben sollte
denn das war schon mal durchgespielt
worden ist sollte jetzt bis zu Ende
gedacht werden so schlimm auch sein mag
aber wir dürfen nicht weiter so aussehen
als wären wir auf alles unvorbereitet es
gibt Möglichkeiten sich vorzubereiten
okay jetzt sind die Zuschauer an der
Reihe sie haben hier sind eine Menge
Menschen die sich schon gemeldet haben
ich beginne mal mit Hans Base aus Lübeck
schönen guten Morgen Herr base
hallo
Herr Basel sie müssen Ihren Fernseher
leise machen und dann guten Morgen jetzt
hören wir Sie Herr Basel bitte schön
ihre Frage okay ich habe eine Frage wir
müssen nicht die Ukraine im Moment die
Suppe auslöffeln die ihn
könnten Sie Ihren Fernseher leise machen
sonst hören wir sie gar nicht
im Moment die Suppe auslöffeln die Ihnen
eine zumindest zum Teil eine verheerende
Politik der Frau Merkel eingebaut hat
klare kurze Frage Herr maskulor was
würden Sie dazu sagen
ich würde sagen das ist nicht ganz so
einfach nicht ist Herr Base aber an
ihrem Argument schon gleichzeitig auch
was dran ist wir haben darüber
gesprochen ich 2014 spätestens wäre aus
meiner Sicht der Moment gewesen wo man
hätte erkennen müssen dass es zu harten
Sanktionen kommen muss damit haben wir
die Diskussion geführt können wir
eigentlich Nord Stream zwei allen
Ernstes weiterbauen in einer solchen
Situation können wir die Energie
Abhängigkeit im Grunde noch fortsetzen
ich glaube die Antwort war damals schon
man durfte nicht aus dem Jahr 2014 kenne
ich die ersten Diskussionen über die
Frage wie geht man eigentlich mal
endlich gegen Oligarchen vor und zwar
gegen die in London aber auch gegen die
am Tegernsee oder die sich in
Norddeutschland ihre Yachten bauen
lassen all diese Sachen sind versickert
ich glaube ab 2014 sind die Signale so
eindeutig gewesen man kann übrigens auch
sagen seit 2008 seitdem Georgienkrieg
aber ich würde sagen spätestens 2014 als
es zum Einsatz militärischer Gewalt
kommt
und der Annexion der Krim ist die
Reaktion des Westens einfach völlig
unzureichend gewesen und dabei hat
Deutschland muss man sagen eine
tragische Rolle gespielt nicht einmal
daran erinnert darf alleine das erste
Paket der Sanktionen dass der Westen
verhängt hat bei dem Überfall auf die
beiden sogenannten Volksrepubliken mit
denen es begann jetzt in den vergangenen
Wochen ist innerhalb des nächsten Tages
in Sanktionen verhängt worden die
umfassender gewesen sind als alle
Sanktionen die wir 2014 nach der Krim
verhängt haben das heißt wir haben
damals ein Jahr lang hin und her
diskutiert und wir haben diese Bedrohung
im Herzen Europas nicht ernst genug
genommen und wir wissen alle wer damals
die Kanzlerin war und sie trägt dafür
ebenfalls so wie viele andere besondere
Verantwortung sie hatte ja einen guten
Draht zu Putin sie spricht russisch
Putin spricht Deutsch wäre das
irgendeine Möglichkeit wenn man sagt man
muss alle Kanäle ausnutzen dass man sagt
Frau Merkel ich glaube daran übrigens
nichts falsch gewesen ist dass die
Kanzlerin des versucht haben übrigens
hat die Kanzlerin das auch nicht ganz
alleine gemacht sondern auch die
US-Administration selbst in Zeiten von
Trump hat sie immer mal gebeten genau
diesen Draht zu nutzen übrigens auch
Gerhard Schröder ist manches Mal
unterwegs gewesen ohne dass es bekannt
gewesen ist und in solchen Fällen ist er
darum gebeten worden bestimmte
vermittlungsmissionen zu unternehmen ich
glaube nur dass es eine Phase gibt so
kenne ich es aus dem Umfeld der
Kanzlerin wo ist ein wo du merkst selbst
wenn er sehr gut Deutsch spricht und sie
spricht sehr gut russisch wo es keinen
Sinn mehr hatte weil Putin begonnen hat
in privaten Gesprächen im Grunde so
ähnlich zu agieren wie wir ihn jetzt
alle öffentlich erleben das heißt er ist
nicht mehr zu erreichen und er sagt die
Unwahrheit kommen wir zur Frau Walz aus
München schönen guten Tag Frau Walz ja
grüß Gott mein Name ist Ralf ich bin
pensionierte hallo ja ich höre sie
stellen sie kurz Ihre Frage bitte ja und
da wollte ich folgendes sagen es gibt
noch einen Ausweg und zwar könnten man
die Ukraine dazu bringen einen
sofortigen Wachstumsstillstand einleiten
arbeiten und in den passiven Widerstand
zu gehen es gibt sogar Beispiele dafür
mal hat man dann die hat das vorgemacht
wie das geht und mit Erfolg gegen die
Engländer dann wollte ich noch was sagen
Herr Putin hat sicher nichts gegen
Demokratie aber er hat Angst dass dein
Land erwischtabilisiert wird und auch
die Belarussen haben das auch das
begründet ist kann man vielleicht in
Frage stellen und dann wollte ich noch
was sagen ich finde es also merkwürdig
dass die Amerikaner sich als
Friedensengel gerieren die haben selber
in Nordafrika ein solches Chaos
angerichtet auch unter verlogenen
vogelnden sind sie in den Irak
eingefallen und das fand ich also alles
andere als appetitlich nur und dabei war
kein aufräumen von Seiten ihren selbst
ja im Westen
und ich glaube
zu leiden okay ich glaube ihre Meinung
ist klar geworden würde ich jetzt
einfach auch mal so stehen lassen
sondern es will jemand dazu was sagen
gab es andere Möglichkeit dass die
Ukraine diese Möglichkeit nicht dass die
Ukraine sich ergeben und das Töten
aufhört erstens weil die Russen glaube
ich weiter töten werden sie werden
Menschen internieren die gekämpft haben
die werden alle jetzt
verhören und und eventuell töten das
sehen wir auch teilweise in den bereits
besetzten Städten das passiert und was
wir vor allem nicht unterschätzen dürfen
die Ukraine werden lieber sterben als
jetzt sich ergeben diesen Kampfgeist
habe ich persönlich schon 2014 gespürt
auf dem Maidan damals als Proteste gegen
den damaligen persischen Präsidenten die
eine kowitsch gab ich war sehr
beeindruckt von den Menschen die gesagt
haben wir sind gekommen um hier zu
protestieren und wir werden nicht
weichen wir wollen keine russischen
Verhältnisse in unserem Land das müssen
sie sich so vorstellen in Russland war
es seit Jahrzehnten normal dass es kaum
Opposition gibt dass wenn Leute zu
Protesten auf dem Roten Platz kommen der
sie von der Polizei verprügelt werden
das war normal in Russland als in der
Ukraine das 2013 passierte zum ersten
Mal das hatten Ausschlag gegeben hat
eine halbe Million Menschen auf die
Straßen geführt das heißt diese Wille in
Freiheit zu leben des extrem stark und
die Menschen sind wirklich bereit zu
sterben dafür kommen wir zum nächsten
Anrufer das ist Daniel Pabst aus Berlin
schönen guten Tag Herr Papst Ihre Frage
bitte ja schönen guten Tag schönen guten
Tag in die Runde schöne Grüße aus Berlin
ich habe eine ich habe eine Frage und
zwar habe ich das Gefühl dass die
langfristigen Folgen dieses Krieges ein
ein bisschen in den Hintergrund geraten
denn je länger dieser Krieg dauert desto
mehr wird die Ukraine zerstört werden
wir erleben jetzt eine unheimlich große
Anzahl von Menschen die auf der Flucht
sind hier in Berlin ganz besonders
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese
Menschen in ein heiles Land zurückkehren
können wird immer kleiner wenn der
Westen diesen Krieg auch immer mehr in
die Länge zieht
also sie sagen man muss sich da viel
mehr darauf einstellen wäre auch die
Frage einfach eher in die Runde sind wir
hier haben wir das noch gar nicht im
Blick was das eigentlich bedeutet also
die humanitärenhilfen die sind natürlich
unglaublich hochgeschossen in den
letzten paar Wochen aber wenn wir jetzt
über darüber überlegen und im Grunde
genommen hat der EU-Gipfel in versaja
schon gesagt ein Schnellverfahren eine
schnell Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine in
der Europäischen Union wird es nicht
geben aber umgekehrt bevor die Ukraine
in die EU kommt muss die EU auf eine
ganz andere Weise erst so Ukraine kommen
und da ist es nämlich genau der Punkt es
muss eine Wiederaufbauhilfe eines
historischen Ausmaßes geben für die
Infrastruktur des Landes für die
Funktionalität des Landes für ganz
prinzipielle Dinge wie Wasserleitungen
Schulen und so weiter Transporter werden
unsere Institutionen die Kreditbank für
Wiederaufbau wieder gefragt werden wie
kein anderes und wenn wir jetzt darüber
nachdenken welche Finanzierungsrahmen
eine EU jetzt aufnehmen muss nicht nur
für den Umbau im Sinne des Klimawandels
und den eigenen Gesellschaften dann
gehört sowas natürlich auch mitgedacht
nicht nur was müssen wir an
Flüchtlingshilfe jetzt leisten können
sondern umgekehrt wie müssen wir die
Ukraine auch wieder aufbauen wenn ich
einen Satz ergänzen darf erfahrt sie
haben ja irgendwie völlig Recht und das
Wort historisch fällt ja in letzter Zeit
irgendwie erstaunlich oft und
unglücklicherweise hat es auch immer
seine Berechtigung wir stehen von dem
historischen Umbau unserer Wirtschaft in
den Bereich der Klimaneutralität weil es
eine Überlebensfrage ist wir stecken
mindestens inmitten einer historischen
Pandemie so schlimm wie seit der
Spanischen Grippe die übrigens auch noch
nicht vorbei ist und jetzt dieser Krieg
immer das ist das was wir in den
vergangenen Monaten erleben den
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel können sie
ja eigentlich heute schon ins Archiv
tragen und sagen davon ist irgendwie
praktisch gar nichts über das heißt das
was wir heute im Moment höchster
Anspannung diskutieren die Folgen von
all dem glaube ich werden uns alle hier
noch sehr lange beschäftigen und sie
sind noch nicht einmal ansatzweise an
diesem Morgen überseebar darf ich ja
über die Folgen für Russland ansprechen
und zwar ich glaube Herr Scholz hat
schon richtig gesagt das zweite Opfer
dieses Krieges ist Russland und dieses
Krieg wird Russland auf Jahre Jahrzehnte
zurückwerfen und das ist eine
Katastrophe für die russische Wirtschaft
für die russische Bevölkerung es wird
wahrscheinlich schlimmer sein als in der
Zeit von breznif und auf Jahre ich weiß
es nicht ob das russische Volk innerer
Kraft findet um eine demokratische
Gesellschaft wieder aufzubauen aber ich
sehe das ist keinen anderen Weg gibt es
gibt noch eine konkrete Frage von Harald
Müller aus Krefeld schönen guten Morgen
Herr Müller ja schönen guten Morgen in
die Runde vielleicht ist meine Frage die
ich stellen werde ja naiv aber sagen die
das russische Volk als Gesamtheit
betrachtet bezeichnet sich einmal als
tief religiös was ich den einzelnen
Menschen noch abnehme wie sieht die
Haltung der russisch-orthodoxen Kirche
aus wäre von Seiten der nicht der
einzelnen Priester sondern der
Institution als Ganzes die Möglichkeit
gegeben auf die
öffentlichkeits informieren Einfluss auf
Putin zu nehmen und einen gewissen Druck
in Russland selbst zu erzeugen fragen
wir mal direkt Frau Rose der Patriarch
der russischen Kirche hat sich der
russischen Regierung angeschlossen er
hat den Krieg befürwortet er hat eher
der hatten Worte gegen die ukrainischen
Narzissten in den fünf Strichen
gerichtet und
tatsache ist dass die russische Kirche
keine moralische Institution im
russischen Volk mehr ist das ist nur ein
Apparat zu Unterstützung von Kreml und
komplett deswegen kann man wirklich
nicht auf die russische Kirche mehr
hoffen ganz davon zu schweigen dass die
russische Bevölkerung nicht besonders
religiös ist sondern einfach nur
traditionell in die Kirche geht und das
tatsächlich
gleichzeitig mit dem Aberglauben
praktiziert was eigentlich nicht
vereinbar ist vielen Dank für ihre
klaren Wort ich glaube als
Friedenskirche ist diese Kirche denkbar
ungeeignet und zwar von ihrem
Patriarchen bis runter zu vielen
Priestern wenn man hört was verkündet
wird
ich glaube wir haben noch Zeit für eine
Frage von Eberhard Michalowski aus
elsleben oder Eisleben hallo Herr
michelowski ja ich hätte die Frage und
zwar wir kaufen weiter Öl und Erdgas
ruhig ein bei den Russen um zu zeigen
dass wir also nichts gegen die russische
Gesellschaft haben nur gegen diesen
Krieg und gegen Putin und legen das Geld
auf ein Sparkonto so dass es der
russischen Gesellschaft erhalten bleibt
für später
konkretes Vorschlag keine Ahnung ob das
so bald praktisch Putin zu
ich würde es mal so stehen lassen und
noch eine Frage dazu nehmen und zwar von
Udo Zöllner aus Herdecke schönen guten
Tag Herr Zellen Zöllner
guten Morgen schönen Gruß in die Runde
meine Frage ist die die Oligarchen die
Gelder von denen sollen oder sind zum
großen Teil eingefroren warum man die
nicht zweckentfremdet dass man ich
stürme das zwar schwierig vor aber
diese Riesen Summen die diese Leute sich
zur Seite geschafft haben wir haben
warum man die nicht humanitär oder sowas
gegen diesen Krieg einsetzen kann damit
ein Zeichen aufgesetzt wird Leute das
kostet euch euer Geld wenn ihr jetzt
hier in diesem Sinne weiter macht
in Gedanken nehme ich irgendwie gerne
erzählen nach vielen Dank dafür jetzt
muss man allerdings sagen dass
Sanktionen prinzipiell nicht dafür
gedacht sind Menschen ihr Geld
abzunehmen sondern Sie müssen es sich im
Grunde feststellen dass alles wird
irgendwie eingefroren einen Schiff läuft
nicht mehr aus eine Wohnung kann nicht
verkauft werden einen Bankkonto kann von
dem kann nichts überwiesen oder
abgehoben werden dass der Sinn der
Sanktion aber ehrlich gesagt im
Vergleich mit viel oder im Umgang mit
vielen dieser
Kleptokraten denn das Russland ist ja
nichts anderes hat es ja ein System wo
man das Gefühl hat es ist die
Kombination aus nackter Unterdrückung
und einem gerade zu obszönen Lebensstil
der Reichen und der Superreichen und in
der sagen wir mal in diesem Bereich gibt
es seit langer Zeit die Idee zu sagen
kann man solche kriminell erworbenen
Vermögen nicht auf eine bessere Art und
Weise abschöpfen und kann man dann mal
aufhören dass die amerikanischen
Steuerbehörden oder die SSC oder wer
auch immer dieses Geld einzieht sondern
dass man es den Menschen zurückgibt den
es gestohlen worden ist oder es für
andere gute Zwecke einsetzen und ich
glaube diesen einen solchen Mechanismus
überall da wo wir gegen diese diese
Mischung aus Diktatur Unterdrückung und
Ausplünderung der eigenen Bevölkerung wo
wir es damit zu tun haben und Russland
ist leider ein deprimierendes Beispiel
dafür brauchen wir endlich Instrumente
dass wenn dieses Geld eingesammelt wird
es guten Zwecken zugeführt wird und das
ist im Zweifel nicht der Deutsche oder
der amerikanische Staat okay ich würde
gerne die letzte Minute nutzen um Ukrain
zur Seite russischer Seite noch eine
Frage zu stellen gibt es wir haben so
viel Negatives besprochen hier und so
viele hier auswegloses gibt es
irgendetwas worauf sie ihre Hoffnung
setzen
zum Stopp und zum Ende des Krieges
ich bin eigentlich hoffnungslos also es
tut mir leid aber ich denke dass der
Westen auf alle Fälle konsequent bleiben
muss und das
weitere Handeln in Bezug auf die
Sanktionen fortsetzen muss und alles
mögliche tun um bei dieser Lehrer zu
bleiben ganz kurz ich bin überzeugt dass
der Westen stärker ist und mittel bis
langfristig auch überlegen sein wird
okay dann nehmen wir das mal als
Schlusspunkt ganz herzlichen Dank für
das Interesse und ihnen noch da sind wir
ganz herzlichen Dank fürs Interesse und
Ihnen noch einen schönen Sonntag
[Musik]